[Music]
I'm gonna talk today about the pleasures
of everyday life but I want to begin
with a story of an unusual and terrible
man this Hermann Goering Goering was a
Hitler's second-in-command in World War
two his designated successor and like
Hitler
Goering fancied himself a collector of
art he went through Europe through order
to stealing extorting and occasionally
buying various paintings first
collection and what he really wanted was
something by Vermeer Hitler had two of
them and he didn't have any so he
finally found an art dealer a Dutch art
dealer named Han Van Meegeren who sold
him a wonderful Vermeer for the cost of
what would now be 10 million dollars and
it was his favorite art work ever world
war ii came to an end and Goering was
captured tried at Nuremberg and
ultimately sentenced to death then the
Allied forces went through his
collections and found the paintings and
went after the people who sold it to him
and at some point the Dutch police came
in Amsterdam and arrested Van Meegeren
then even was charged with the crime of
treason which is itself punishable by
death six weeks into his prison sentence
Van Meegeren confessed but he didn't
confess to treason he said I did not
sell a great masterpiece to that Nazi I
painted it myself I'm a forger nobody
now nobody believed him and he said I'll
prove it bring me a canvas and some
paint and I will paint a Vermeer much
better than I sold that disgusting Nazi
I also need alcohol and morphine because
it's the only way I can work
so they brought him and he painted a
beautiful Vermeer and then he the
charges of treason were dropped
he had a lesser charge a forgery got a
year sentence and died a hero to the
Dutch people there's a lot more to be
said about Van Meegeren but I want to
turn now to Goering who's pictured here
being interrogated at Nuremberg now
Goering was by all accounts a terrible
man even for a Nazi he was a terrible
man his American interrogators described
him as an amicable psychopath but you
could feel sympathy for the reaction he
had when he was told that his favorite
painting was actually a forgery
according to his biographer he looked as
if for the first time he had discovered
her was evil
and he killed himself soon afterwards he
had discovered after all that the
painting he thought was this was
actually that it looked the same but it
had a different origin it was a
different artwork it wasn't just him who
was in for a shock once when negan was
on trial he couldn't stop talking and he
boasted about all the great masterpieces
that he himself had painted that were
attributed to other artists in
particular the supper at Emmaus which
was viewed as Premier's finest
masterpieces best where people come all
over the world to see it was actually a
forgery it was not that painting but
that painting and when that was
discovered it lost all its value was
taken away from the museum why does this
matter
I'm a psychologist why do origins matter
so much why do we respond so much to our
knowledge of where something comes from
well there's an answer that many people
would give many sociologists like a
villain and wolf would argue that the
reason why we take origins so seriously
is because we're snobs because we're
focused on status among other things if
you want to show off how rich you are
how powerful you are it's always better
to own an original than a forgery
because it's always gonna be fewer
originals and forgeries I don't doubt
that that plays some role but what I
want to convince you today is that
there's something else going on I want
to convince you that humans are to some
extent natural-born essentialists what I
mean by this is we don't just respond to
things as we see them or feel them or
hear them rather our response is
conditioned on our beliefs about what
they really are where they came from
what they're made of what their hidden
nature is I want to suggest that this is
true not just for how we think about
things but how we react to things so I
want to suggest a pleasure is deep and
if this isn't true just for sort of
higher level pleasures like art but even
the most seemingly simple pleasures are
affected by our beliefs about hidden
essences so take food would you eat this
well a good answer is it depends what is
it some of you would eat it if it's pork
but not beef some of you would eat it if
it's beef but not pork
you of you would eat it if it's a rat or
a human some of you would eat it only if
it's a strangely colored piece of tofu
that's not so surprising but what's more
interesting is how it tastes to you will
depend critically on what you think
you're eating so one demonstration of
this was done with young children how do
you make children not just be more
likely to eat carrots and drink milk but
to get more pleasure from eating carrots
and drinking milk just think they taste
better it's simple you tell them and
from McDonald's they believe McDonald's
food is tastier and it leads them to
experience it as tastier how do you get
adults to really enjoy wine it's very
simple pour it from an expensive bottle
there are now dozens perhaps hundreds of
studies showing that if you believe
you're drinking the expensive stuff it
tastes better to you this was recently
done with a neuroscientific twist they
get people in an fMRI scanner and while
they're lying there through a tube they
get to sip wine in front of them on a
screen is information about the wine
everybody of course drinks exactly the
same wine but if you believe you're
drinking expensive stuff parts of the
brain associated with pleasure and
reward light up like a Christmas tree
it's not just then you're say it's more
pleasurable you say you like more you
really experience it in a different way
or take sex
these are stimuli of use in some of my
studies and if you simply show people
these pictures they'll say these are
fairly attractive people
but how attractive you find them how
sexually or romantically move you are by
them rest critically on who you think
you're looking at you probably think the
picture on the left is male the one on
the right is female if that believe
turns out to be mistaken it will make a
difference
it will make a difference if they turn
out to be much younger or much older
than you think they are it make a
difference if you were discovered at the
person you're looking at with lust is
actually a disguised version of your son
or daughter your mother or father
knowing somebody's you can't typically
kills the libido may be one of the most
heartening findings from the psychology
of pleasure is there's more to looking
good than your physical appearance if
you like somebody they look better to
you
this is why spouses and happy marriages
tend to think that our husband or wife
looks much better than anyone else
thinks that they do a particularly
dramatic example of this comes from a
neurological disorder known as Capgras
syndrome so comp breast syndrome is a
disorder where you get a specific
delusion sufferers of capra syndrome
believe that the people they love most
in the world have been replaced by
perfect duplicates now often a result of
Capgras syndrome is tragic people have
murdered those that they love believing
that they were murdering an imposter but
there's at least one case where Capgras
syndrome had a happy ending
this was reported in 1931 research
described a woman with compris syndrome
who complained about her poorly endowed
and sexually inadequate lover but that
was before she got Capgras syndrome
after she got it she was happy to report
that she has discovered he possessed a
double who was rich virile handsome and
aristocratic
of course it was the same man but she
was seeing him in different ways as a
third example consider consumer products
so one reason why you might like
something is its utility you can put
shoes on your feet you can play golf of
golf clubs and chewed-up bubble gum
doesn't do anything at all for you but
each of these three objects has value
above and beyond what it can do for you
based on its history the golf clubs were
owned by John F Kennedy and sold for
three-quarters of a million dollars at
auction the bubble gum was chewed up by
pop star Britney Spears and so for
several hundreds of dollars and in fact
there's a thriving market and a
partially eaten food of beloved people
the shoes are perhaps the most valuable
of all according to an unconfirmed
report a Saudi millionaire offered ten
million dollars for this pair of shoes
they were the ones thrown at George Bush
at an Iraqi press conference several
years ago now this attraction to objects
doesn't just work for celebrity objects
each one of us most people have
something in her life that's literally
irreplaceable in that it has value
because of its history maybe your
wedding ring maybe your child's baby
shoes so that if it was lost you
couldn't get it back you could get
something to look like it or felt like
it you couldn't get the same object back
with my colleagues George Newman and
Gilda Sandra we've looked to see what
sort of factors what sort of history
matters for the objects that people like
so in one of our experiments we asked
people to name a famous person who who
they adored a living person they adored
so one answer was George Clooney then we
asked him how much would you pay for
George Clooney's sweater and the answer
is a fair amount more than you would pay
for a brand-new sweater or a sweater
owned by somebody who you did in the
door then we asked other groups of
subjects we gave them different
restrictions and different conditions so
for instance we told some people look
you can buy the sweater but you can't
tell anybody you own it and you can't
resell it that drops the value of it
suggesting that has one reason why we
like it but what really causes an effect
is you tell people look you could resell
it you could boast about it but before
it gets to you it's thoroughly washed
that causes a huge drop in the value
as my wife put it you've washed away the
couny cooties so let's go back to art I
would love a Chagall I love the work of
Chagall if people want to get me
something at the end of the conference
you could buy me a Chagall
but I don't want a duplicate even if I
can tell the difference that's not
because are it's not simply because I'm
a snob and want to boast about having an
original rather it's because I want
something has a specific history in the
case of artwork the history is special
indeed the philosopher Dennis Dutton and
his wonderful book the art instinct
makes the case that the value of an
artwork is rooted in assumptions about a
human performance underlying its
creation and that could explain the
difference between original and a
forgery they may look alike but they
have a different history the original is
typically the product of a creative act
the forgery isn't I think this approach
can explain differences in people's
taste in art this is a work by Jackson
Pollock who here likes to work on
Jackson Pollock okay who here does
nothing for them they just don't like it
okay I'm not gonna make a claim about
about who's right but I will make an
empirical claim about people's
intuitions which is that if you like the
work of Jackson Pollock you don't tend
more so than the people who don't like
it to believe that Leeds works are
difficult to create that they require a
lot of time and energy and creative
energy I use Jackson Pollock on purpose
as an example because there's a young
American artist who paints very much in
the style of Jackson Pollock and her
work was worth many tens of thousands of
dollars in large part because she's a
very young artist this is Marla Olmstead
who did most of her work when she was
three years old the interesting point
about Marla Olmstead is her family made
the mistake of inviting the television
program 60 minutes to into their house
to film her painting and they then
reported that her father was coaching
her when this came out on television the
value of her art dropped to nothing
it was the same art physically but the
history had changed I've been focusing
now on her visual arts but I want to
give two examples from music this is
Joshua Bell a very famous violinist and
the Washington Post reporter gene
garden decided to enlist him for an
audacious experiment the question is how
much would people like Joshua Bell the
music of Joshua Bell if they didn't know
they were listening to Joshua Bell so he
got Joshua Bell to take his
million-dollar violin down to a
Washington DC subway station and stand
in the corner and see how much money he
would make and there's a brief clip of
this
[Music]
after being there for three quarters of
an hour he made $32 not bad it's also
not good apparently to really enjoy the
music of Joshua Bell you have to know
you're listening to Joshua Bell he
actually made $20 it's more than that
but they didn't count it because this
woman comes up you see her to enter the
video she comes up she had heard him at
the Library of Congress a few weeks
before this extravagant black-tie affair
so she's stunned that he's standing in a
subway station and so she struck with
pity she reaches into her person hands
him a 20 the second example from music
is from John Cage's modernist
composition 4 minutes 33 seconds as many
of you know this is a composition where
the pianist sits at a bench opens up the
piano and sits and does nothing for 4
minutes and 33 seconds that period of
silence and people have different views
on us but what I want to point out is
you can buy this from iTunes for a
dollar ninety-nine you could listen to
that silence which is different than
other forms of silence
now I've been talking so far about
pleasure
but what I want to suggest is the same
everything I've said applies as well to
pain and how do you think about what
you're experiencing your beliefs about
the essence of it affect how it hurts
one lovely experiment was done by Curt
gray and Dan Wagner what they did was
they hooked up Harvard undergraduates an
electric shock machine and he gave it a
series of painful electric shocks so
there's a series of five painful shocks
half of them are told that they're being
given the shocks by somebody in another
room but a person other room doesn't
know what they're giving him shots
there's no malevolent in just pressing a
button the first shock is recorded as
very painful the second shock feels less
painful because you get a bit used to it
the third drops to fourth and the fifth
digit the pain gets less in the other
condition they're told that the person
in the next room is shocking them on
purpose knows you're shocking it the
first shock hurts like hell the second
shock hurts just as much and the third
and the fourth and the fifth it hurts
more if you believe somebody is doing it
to you on purpose the most extreme
example of this is that in some cases
pain under the right circumstances can
transform into pleasure humans have this
extraordinarily interesting property
that will often seek out low-level doses
of pain in controlled circumstance and
take pleasure from it as in the eating
of Hot Chili Peppers and rollercoaster
rides the point was nicely summarized by
the poet John Milton who wrote the mind
is its own place and in itself can make
a heaven of Hell a hell of heaven and
I'll end with that thank you
[Applause]
[Music]